herr präsident meine damen und herren
vor bundeskanzlerin als heinrich heine
1832 in frankreich
der deutschen auswahl nach und nach
übersee begegnete notierte er all diese
armen leute hätten im gegen ihr elend
geklagt aber immer mit der frage geendet
was sollen wir tun sollen wir eine
revolution anfangen die schwere fährt
eine ford der zehnte teil von dem was
jene leute in deutschland geduldet haben
hätte in frankreich 36 revolution
hervorgebracht
angesichts der landesweiten proteste
französischer autofahrer gegen die
benzinpreiserhöhungen der regierung muss
sich spontan an heinrich heine denken
diesem satz die wutrede einer
51-jährigen bretonen und diesel fahren
wurde von millionen franzosen angeklickt
vor 10 jahren habt ihr uns dazu gebracht
diese zu kaufen weil sie als
umweltfreundlicher galten ruf die
bretonen an die adresse von präsident
marc ihren heiligen und jetzt wolle man
die dieselfahrer mit einer deftigen
steuererhöhungen abkassiert
ob diese demonstrationen auch
deutschland bereichen gründe dafür gäbe
es genügend
immerhin
hat die deutsche umwelthilfe gerade vor
gericht ein diesel fahrverbot auf der
a40 durchgesetzt einmal
hauptverkehrsader des ruhrgebiets
das trifft pendler noch härter als
preiserhöhungen werden die dieselfahrer
in nrw jetzt auf die straße gehen wohl
eher nicht eilig eine kannte den grund
die deutsche geduld und die französische
unterscheiden sich sehr
meine damen und herren wir alle haben
den bewegenden auftritt von mandl makro
vor dem deutschen bundestag miterlebt
seinen aufruf zum noch festeren deutsch
französischen schulterschluss und zur
deutsch-französischen solidarität gehört
gern meine damen und herren den
protestierenden französischen
autofahrern gehört unsere ungeteilte
sympathie in einem zeitungsinterview
erklärte alexis bier forschungsdirektor
am centre national de la recherche
scientifique einer der gründe für die
proteste sei dass steuerzahler am
unteren ende der sozialen pyramide keine
gegenleistung mehr zu sehen bekommen
für das was sie einst sagen es sei nicht
überraschend dass die bewegung in
ländlichen gebieten und mittelgroßen
städten entstanden ist diese territorien
litten seit langem unter dem allgemeinen
niedergang und der verschlechterung
öffentlicher dienstleistungen ist das so
weit weg von unseren eigenen problemen
den abgehängten regionen meine damen und
herren
bevor er im namen frankreichs seine
betörende liebeserklärung an deutschland
aus sprach sagte präsident marco ich
zitiere jeder von uns wird im sinne
einer vergemeinschaftung seine
entscheidungsbefugnisse seiner
außenpolitik seine migration oder
entwicklungspolitik sowie einen
wachsenden teil seines haushaltes oder
sogar seiner steuer ein
teilen müssen nun meine damen und herren
es wäre nicht die erste aus finanziellen
gründen arrangierte ehe die öffentlich
als liebesheirat verkauft
was uns betrifft wir bekennen uns zu
jenem wie ihr vertrag der in maastricht
geschlossen wurde und der gerade nicht
eine teilung der steuereinnahmen zur
übernahme der schulden anderer vorsieht
und dabei wollen wir auch bleiben
ich habe diese stelle schon einmal
darauf hingewiesen dass es nur ein
bruchteil der deutschen bevölkerung ist
dem wir die tatsache verdanken
überhaupt einen haushalt planen zu
können ungefähr 15 millionen wirkliche
steuerzahler halten den laden hier am
laufen
sie müssen alles schultern die unsummen
der energiewende der massenimmigration
der sogenannten euro-rettung und nun
also als klimarettung verkaufte
automobile feindschaft großzügig für die
bundesregierung den grenzwert für
stickoxide im straßenverkehr von 40
mikrogramm pro kubikmeter luft auf 50
mikrogramm anheben
frau bundeskanzlerin er hat das
ausgeführt um diesel fahrer wurde in
städten zu vermeiden
bis heute gibt es freilich keinen beleg
dafür dass eine stickoxid konzentration
über 40 mikrogramm gesundheitsschäden
auslösen
der grenzwert für die stickoxid
konzentration einen gewerblichen
arbeitsplätze liegt in deutschland und
in der eu
übrigens bei 950 mikrogramm
der lungenfacharzt und ehemalige
präsident der deutschen neurologen des
deutschen pneumologe verbandes professor
dieter köhler hat erklärt die eu
grenzwerte für stickoxide und feinstaub
bezeichneten in keiner weise irgendeine
gesundheitsgefährdung schwelle in
deutschland sei noch niemand durch
stickoxide gestorben
[Applaus]
aber meine damen und herren es geht hier
in wirklichkeit auch nicht um abgasen
höhere werte es geht nicht um stickoxide
sonnen hochmoor halten mit der hoch
moral verhält es sich so dass die einen
sie predigen und die handlung sie
bezahlen wenn grüne apostel in politik
und medien den menschen jetzt erklären
dass wir künftig eben mehr zu fuß gehen
mit dem rad oder der bahn fahren müssten
also die menschen nicht die apostel dann
ist das zugleich die aufforderungen mund
halten und zahlen es sei denn die
menschen nehmen sich ein beispiel den
franzosen und gehen auf die straße und
protestieren meine damen und herren zur
feinstaub und stickoxide gelten penibel
überwacht obergrenzen für migration
bekanntlich nicht dabei sind sie
gelegentlich sind die gelegentlich
tödlichen nebenwirkungen von migration
im gegensatz zum feinstaub
offensichtlich
eben erst hat in wittenburg ein
abgelehnter aber geduldet da
afghanischer asylbewerber einem rentner
die kehle durchgeschnitten
was nicht zu hass und hetze führen darf
wie der zuständige innenminister sofort
anmerkt
obendrein kostet migration beachtliche
summen die von der bundesregierung
übrigens diskret geschwiegen werden
ich sitze jeder die flüchtlings kosten
werden auf viele etats verteilt wer bei
der berliner regierung nach der
gesamtsumme fragt wird in ein labyrinth
von statistiken und zuständigkeiten
geschickt nur die eine ins entscheidende
zahl gibt es nicht die aller
aufwendungen für einen klar definierten
personenkreis ist nicht von mir das
schrieb die neue zürcher zeitung
[Applaus]
entwicklungshilfeminister gerd müller
von 30 milliarden euro die bund länder
und gemeinden pro jahr für eine million
migranten ausgeben
der ungefähr anderthalb millionen
tatsächliche und angebliche flüchtlinge
seit 2015 zu uns gekommen sind wären das
55 milliarden euro im jahr
das institut der deutschen wirtschaft
kommt auf 50 milliarden das kieler
institut für wirtschaftsforschung auf
bis zu 55 milliarden
zum vergleich haushalt die ausgaben für
erziehungs und elterngeld des bundes
betrugen im vergangenen jahr 6,4
milliarden für bundesautobahnen und
bundesstraßen 6,6 milliarden
der jahresetat des
bundesforschungsministeriums unsere
zukunft liegt bei 17 milliarden euro
aber meine damen und herren ist das geld
wenigstens gut angelegt ein großteil der
aktuellen einwanderung gehört in die
kategorie primär oder sekunden
70 prozent der immigranten brechen laut
handwerkskammer ihre lehre ab jeder
zweite arbeitslose in westdeutschland
hatte 2017 einen migrationshintergrund
etwa 30 prozent der häftlinge in
deutschen gefängnissen sind ausländer
zugleich müssen sich einer studie des
wdr zufolge 40 prozent der deutschen auf
altersarmut einstellen
fast jedem zweiten bundesbürger näher ab
2030 in rente geht drohe eine
altersversorgung aus der gesetzlichen
rentenversicherung unterhalb der
armutsgrenze
die zahl der menschen ohne wohnung wuchs
von 248.000 personen im jahr 2010 auf
dann rund 35.000 person ende 2016
wie die bundesregierung auf eine anfrage
der linken antwortete über die zustände
an öffentlichen schulen bädern und parks
ließ man wenig erfreuliches es fehlt
überall an geld obwohl wir an
üblich so viel haben ich weiß meine
damen und herren auf der linken seite
des hauses sie werden jetzt wieder sagen
die afg spiele ausländer gegen deutschen
sozial felder aus aber ich habe
lediglich ein paar fakten aufgezählt
sozialstaat und offene grenzen das kann
niemals zusammen funktionieren das ist
ungefähr so als wenn man im winter das
fenster aufreißt und zugleich die
heizung immer höher dreht um die
temperatur zu halten
gut die aktuelle migration kostet viel
und rentiert sich nur wenig aber wir
haben doch wenigstens geholfen meine
damen und herren ich bitte sie sich eine
zahl gut einzuprägen
die bevölkerung afrikas wächst alle
zwölf tage um eine million menschen
das heißt jene etwa anderthalb millionen
migranten die auf grund von frau merkels
politik der offenen grenzen september
2015 zu uns geströmt sind und unser land
vor enorme schwierigkeiten stellen
werden in afrika in 18 tagen nach
geboren was wir getan haben und tun
werden wird dort nicht einmal bemerkt
obwohl die bisherigen erfahrungen mit
der migration nicht die besten sind wie
die bundesregierung ja nun in wenigen
tagen im global compact von migration
beitreten
diese global compact der völlig
unverbindlich ist aber fluchtursachen
bekämpfen soll nennt die haupt flucht
ursache mit keiner silbe
die bevölkerungsexplosion wer europa als
abschluss becken dafür anbietet wird
europa schwächen und afrika kein
bisschen helfen
viele länder auch viele europäer werden
das dokument nicht unterzeichnen
nun hat auch israel nein gesagt und da
bin ich mal auf die erklärung gespannt
dem bundestag liegen derzeit mindestens
17 petitionen gegen den pakt foren auch
in der union wächst der widerstand gegen
die herrscher der
bundesgesundheitsminister will über ihn
abstimmen lassen
der vorsitzende des bundestagsausschuss
für wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit und
entwicklung herum sauer ist der meinung
der pakt öffnet dem flüchtlingsstrom
nach deutschland tür und tor
das ist einer ihrer abgeordneten
liebe kollegen bei der cdu wird union
sagt integration ja migrations packt
nein danke recht haben sie
der öffentlichkeit wird immer erklärt
die global compact so unverbindlich
er ist rechtlich nicht bindend und
deshalb steht deutschland dazu sagte die
bundeskanzlerin anfang februar in
warschau bei einem treffen mit dem
polnischen ministerpräsidenten
liebe frau bundeskanzlerin eine reizende
miniatur in politischer doppelmoral
zugleich hören wir
der pakt soll die weltweite migration
ordnen die illegale einwanderung
eindämmen und das schlepper wesen
bekämpfen
meine damen und herren auf der
regierungsbank gründen sie der
öffentlichkeit einmal erklären wie das
funktionieren soll mit einem völlig
unverbindlichen papier viel vergnügen
bei der erklärung
ich weiß schon warum heraus dass ich
macht was nicht kannte wir fordern ein
ende dieser experimente die probleme die
diese regierung unserem land aufgebaut
hat sind ohnehin kaum zu schultern hören
sie auf ihre politik an illusionen
auszurichten
ich will deshalb heute nicht mit einem
zitat bismarck schließen was ich gerne
mache somit abraham lincoln
ihr wäre die schwachen nicht stärken
indem wir die starken schwächt ihr
werdet dienen die ihren lebensunterhalt
verdienen müssen nicht helfen indem ihr
die ruiniert in die zahlen
dankeschön
[Applaus]